heroes in OverWatch are some of the most
meticulously designed and well-crafted
characters in the business here are 24
characters that either evolved into the
heroes we know and love today or got
left on The Cutting Room floor
number one Brit Brit uses a pistol
support Mech and attack Mech she is
believed to be the Prototype of the Tank
Hero Diva due to the similarities in
their abilities she actually appears in
game on a billboard for the virtual
travel agency on the kanazaka map
number two Bruiser Bruiser is a robot
whose main abilities are wrist chain
guns he's believed to be the concept
that evolved into Bob due to the
forehead robot design similarities and
the chain guns of course
number three Fire Starter Firestarter is
a Mech Warrior character that uses the
abilities slag gun molotovs And Eruption
the slag gun in particular could have
been a prototype for torbjorn's molten
core if you look at the description for
molten core it describes shooting pools
of molten slag so there you go
number four Frost to balance out the
Firebase stabilities of Firestarter the
team created Frost with the abilities
ice ax ice patch and Ice wall the
Prototype connection is strong here as
frostability ice wall eventually ended
up with May in the final game
number five Helio a member of the
support class Helio used the abilities
healing light protection and electric
maces although he doesn't appear in game
he does show up in the animated short
recall with some slight armor
adjustments
number six hive mind hive mind is a
lightning gun-wielding bio-engineered
concept that seems to have been placed
in a variety of different heroes in game
his EMP pulse ability may have inspired
the EMP and hacking abilities in
sombra's moveset although his color
scheme is closer to moira's his physical
design with the large Tech Armor
protruding from his head most similar to
Sigma
number seven Huntress one of the
strongest connections so far from
prototype to hero is Huntress to Hanzo
huntress's abilities are crossbow
multi-shot and imbue shot crossbow got
turned into a bow for Hanzo multi-shot
got reworked to storm arrows and while I
don't know exactly what the imbue shot
would entail it sounds very similar in
concept to hanzo's Sonic Arrow
number eight jetpack cat one of the most
cataloged unused heroes in the OverWatch
Mythos jetpack cat was introduced to the
world during an interview with
ex-overwatch director Jeff Kaplan by
gamespot's illustrious managing editor
and after dark host Timor Hussein then
there was this one hero that was a huge
internal debate on the team because we
just loved it so much but couldn't make
it it was this jet pack and it had this
cat that laid in it like a cat does then
every once in a while it would pause the
controls it was a cat in a jet pack
although fans would never get the chance
to play as the frisky feline jetpack cat
is a part of the greater OverWatch canon
in early stages senior lore Designer
Michael Chu stated that torbjorn has a
particularly interesting cat and who
knows what stuff torbjorn has lying
around jetpack cat would have been a
shop cat for torbjorn as part of his
lore when Bridget Lindholm was
introduced as a new hero in 2018 her
lore video shows her family with a
fluffy white cat which she eventually
ended up making an entire set of armor
for although not the same cat it is
confirmed that the initial idea for
Bridget's pet came from jetpack cat
number nine Luke the outwardly demonic
Luke presumably short for Lucifer uses
the abilities chain sword spawn minions
and Flame strike the only connective
tissue I can find to the actual game is
that flame strike is similar to
reinhardt's fire strike ability
number 10 Mama Hong Mama Hong is a
character with only one known ability
her design was supposedly based off of
the landlady from Kung Fu Hustle and was
one of the most controversial Heroes
among the dev team to be added into the
game she was taken out of the Running by
Wrecking Ball
number 11 McLeod McLeod is a Scottish
hero with the abilities Claymore only
one and Stampede only one refers to the
Outlander series of books and TV show
and in the echelon Club on Kings Road
there's a painting with Scottish
characters with blue face paint the main
subject on Horseback is strikingly
similar to the McLeod concept art his
depiction on Horseback could also allude
to his Stampede ability
number 12 overmind overmind has the
abilities Dark Matter gun void Spear and
absorb they're believed to be the
inspiration for both Moira and sigma's
abilities as well as a reference to the
Starcraft universe
number 13 Phoenix the flamethrower
welding flying concept character stems
from Jeff kaplan's initial pitch for a
rocket launch character in addition to
the explodability and ability called
jetpack and Napalm call down were used
during the pitch for Phoenix Phoenix
would be the inspiration for one of the
earliest Heroes developed pharah
number 14 freak freak derives her name
from a portmanteau of phone and freak in
real life freaking is a slang term used
in describing reverse engineering and
hacking a phone system although not
playable she may exist in the current
lore of OverWatch during the beginning
of the cinematic trailer for OverWatch
the Paris scene of the slideshow has a
figure with freak written on the back of
their jacket
number 15 prietor although he derives
his name from an ancient Roman position
prytor shares more in common with the
most prominent American OverWatch hero
both the tri-grenade and Hunter Vision
are thought to be the precursors to
Soldier 76's abilities Helix rocket in
tactical visor prior to his final
ability twin cannons as well as his
fully armored look are inspiration for
the Talon heavy assault Infantry
number 16 cyblade not much is known
about the development of cyblade
although somewhat similar to Widowmaker
in appearance her abilities Super Punch
Shockwave and backbreaker seem more in
line with doomfist's abilities her name
comes from the cyblade weapon in
Starcraft
number 17 Rashi other than her abilities
damage beam strike and mass heal all
that is known about Rashi is that her
name refers to the signs in Hindu
astrology potentially linking her to
symmetra in game
number 18 recluse recluse has been shown
a few times over the development of
OverWatch she was part of a piece of
concept art that was shown off at the
dice conference in 2017 where she is
shown using her only known ability mouth
beam she also has a potential second
ability to spawn quadruped robots Jeff
Kaplan stated hero in the center is not
the hero who he thinks think it is
leading many to think she would be the
24th hero who turned out to be erisa
number 19 Rumble speaking of erisa the
character Rumble may be the precursor to
the quadruped tank its abilities Siege
mode stationary shield and energy bolt
are similar to erisa's fortify infusion
driver abilities
number 20 Shield guy Shield guy is the
most nebulous of the bunch pitched to
the team by artist Ki Fang Shield guy
was heavily armored but the projected
shield and beam weapon as part of the
Talon response Squad the team couldn't
seem to place him though with his beam
never feeling quite right in play tests
and silhouette not easily identifiable
number 21 Troy with his flail charge and
shield Troy is thought to be the
influence for Bridget's abilities
number 22 Watcher Watcher's abilities
featured a staff gun transfusion and
teleport transfusion and teleport are
thought to be the main inspiration for
moira's abilities
number 23 wildebeest wildebeest has a
storied past within the development of
OverWatch starting in several
promotional illustrations of the hero
lineup for the game he was featured in
the recall animated short alongside
Winston and Helio elements of his design
were used for orisa and his flail and
shield combo would be worked into the
Bridget hero design
number 24 yetzi Yeti is a play on the
mythological Beast and the only hard and
fast facts we have are his kit of claws
ice storm and free snap
[Music]
special note Genji and Hanzo were
originally one character just called
Genji that had both a sword and a bow
in the last six years overwatch's Heroes
Have Become some of the most iconic
characters in video games it has been
fascinating to explore all the different
Design Elements and deliberate choices
the team made to create such a unique
roster of characters with the addition
of More Heroes at launch and many more
updates coming with OverWatch too I
cannot wait to see what new types of
heroes that blizzard can cook up catch
me on Twitter at Stewie review and for
everything OverWatch keep it here at
GameSpot